[Music]
what up guys goes on here for anime up
drawer and today we have a video you
guys kept suggesting ever since our
first video which was every quirk in
class 1-a explain I'm not even joking we
literally received multiple requests for
this one on every my hero academia video
we put out well we heard you guys loud
and clear and today we are finally going
to go through everything you need to
know about the students of class 1v and
their quirks now obviously we have less
information about this class then class
1a the class with all of our main
characters but at the very least
thanks to my hero academia data book we
know the name of everyone's quirk and
can use the existing knowledge from the
anime and manga to fill in most the
details if you haven't already be sure
to subscribe for more my hero academia
videos like this one there will not be
any major spoilers in this video so you
don't need to worry about that
Mathew psyched and ready to go the
United States of smash that like button
and let's do this first up we have natal
monomyth his quirk is called copy and
the quirk type is transformed NATO's
power is a dinner of quirks in the world
of my hero academia he just needs to
make contact with his target and as the
name suggests he can copy their quirk
and use it for himself once he copied
someone's quirk he seems to know how to
activate and utilize every course even
if he has no experience with it this may
have something to do with his
intelligence which is an impressive 5
out of 5 according to the data book I'm
really curious to see how well he could
use one for all if he ever copied it
from midoriya because we know how hard
Deku has worked to control his own quirk
NATO can copy multiple quirks at once
which is of course an amazing power but
it's not without its limitations
obviously making contact with your
opponent in the first place is not
always going to be the easy thing to do
especially if the opponent is
knowledgeable and wary of his copying
quirk however when collaboration is
possible NATO does always have the
option of copying the quirks of an
allies it is also important to note that
each copy
work can only be used for five minutes
after contact and then NATO will lose
access to it unless he makes contact
once more also although he can copy
multiple works at the same time he
cannot use the quirks simultaneously
imagine if he just copied to the Rockies
quark tus quark and eraser head squirt
and use them at the same time now that
would be insane anyways we have seen him
successfully copy the following quirks
explosion hardening scales and solid air
next we have Jews alone a new key whose
quark is called softness the quark type
is emitter and it is classified as a
long range quark pretty much useless
quark allows us to soften anything he
touches and we saw him use this court to
turn the ground into quicksand as a way
of immobilizing his opponent his quark
can also be a very useful defensive
weapon since he can potentially soften
the blows of enemy attacks and use it to
escape tight spot it would be hard to
keep this guy trapped somewhere if he
can just turn the walls into quicksand
it has also been pointed out that his
appearance resembles out of air Yeager's
Titan in attack on Titan coincidence
probably next we have ketsu ketsu ketsu
ketsu so I just say the same name twice
yes yes I did is redundant yes yes it is
his quirk is called steel and its type
is transformation his quirk lets him
turn his entire body into steel it is
strikingly similar to hardening and it
is also said to be simultaneously the
strongest attack and the strongest
defense there is a drawback to his cool
Silver Surfer s power
if Tetsu Tetsu uses the court for too
long he'll start suffering from iron
fatigue the amount of iron that he
consumes and his food appears to affect
the Hardison length of his field
transformation you guys may also like to
know that pet suit pets who loves video
games in spinach and coal hey the
mangaka loves his design and has said
that he wants to draw more of him so
don't be surprised if we see more
development for him in the near future
next up we have the lovable fan favorite
itsuka Kendall she is the one that is
always apologizing to class 1-a for
NATO's insane behavior her quirk is
called big fist and it's typist
transformation as the name suggests she
does have man hands she can enlarge her
hands to a gigantic size the clerk
allows her to enlarge one hand at a time
or both hands simultaneously her quirk
is very versatile it comes in handy with
hand-to-hand combat the big fist also
increases her strength allowing her to
grab and carry people in the air her
hands are so powerful that she can even
create a temporary whirlwind using them
Asuka actually ranked 13th in the first
my hero academia popularity polls making
her the most popular class 1b character
according to the mangaka she is also
very popular among his staff and you may
also like to know that she is a big fan
of black coffee and motorcycles next up
we had here you Dean who's quark is
called scales
it's quark type this transformation and
it works at close range the quark lets
him turn his skin to scale which
increases his combat capabilities in
terms of defense and offense he has only
been seen to use this power on his arm
so far but it is likely that he can or
will eventually be able to cover his
whole body and top scales kind of like
Tetsu Tetsu can cover his whole body
with steel like most characters he of
you is fittingly named the country's and
his name means scaled and flying dragon
so it's possible that he'll use quark is
similar to dragoon hero Luke use quark
which allowed her to turn into a dragon
perhaps with enough practice here you
will be able to create a larger scale
transformation like the Dragoon heroes
he is not Japanese he's a foreign
student but like me his favorite food is
sushi next up we had your suit suit
allison whose quark is called weld his
quark type is emitter and it is a
close-range quirk since it works on
contact he is able to melt or fuse
things together if he is touching both
objects his fusions are not quite as
glamorous or epoch as Goku and Vegeta's
but they get the job done
when he's not welding things together
yes sir two likes to play games on his
phone
next up we have kool-aid subbu dolla his
quirk is called solid air it's tight as
a minner
and his quirk works at close range his
quirk let's go say solidify air using
his breath he can create a solid wall
but the size is limited by closes lung
capacity it's interesting to note that
the solidified wall of air will stay
afloat rather than fall to the ground
even if a character is hanging off of it
a drawback is that the walls are not
very strong and characters like buckle
go can break through them with a single
punch however as he hones his quirk
it is possible as a hardness of co-signs
walls of air will increase next up we
have the strong body and creepy headed
core judo bundle and his quirk is called
semi die it's type is a minaret and it
works at medium range the quirk lets him
shoot a glue-like fluid from the holes
in his strange head he is pretty much a
walking talking tube of glue like glue
the liquid that shoots from his head
hardens quickly and is useful for
trapping opponents as we've seen Nina
asados acid quirk
can contracted since the acid dissolves
the glue like substance
kojirou squirt also comes in handy for
his favorite hobby he enjoys putting
together scale model bonus fact his
quirk is actually named after an
adhesive that is popular in Japan next
up we have Yui cool dies her quick is
called size and the core type is
transformation the quirk lets the
possessor change her body size she has
been seen enlarging herself and
shrinking down to less than a meter tall
unlike mount lady who can only grow to
one specific size it seems that Yui
squirt has more flexibility since she
can grow and shrink and possibly control
how big or small she get her name is
very appropriate for her quirk since it
contains the country's four small and
big I love how even the students hobbies
are usually connected to their quirk and
this is definitely the case for Yui she
loves matreoshka dolls or Russian
nesting dolls a Russian nesting doll is
a set of wooden dolls of decreasing size
play
one inside another like the dolls Yui
comes in a variety of sizes next up we
have Ibanez she Ozaki her quark is
called mine that it's type is mutant it
works a medium range instead of hair she
grows powerful vines out of her head
which you can use to attack defend or
grab people things
her vines can travel through the ground
and they have considerable reach even if
the vines are cut off
you better can still control them also
if someone were to cut off all of the
vines you bet I would be bald to regrow
her head of mine she needs to soak her
head with water bathed in sunlight and
just let photosynthesis do its thing
you better got a perfect 5 out of 5
score for technique in the official data
book suggesting that her quirk is among
the best bonus facts she was originally
going to be in class 1a but the mangaka
was not a fan of drawing her hair
although it looks cool
he found the process to be too painful
next we had Nia and Jackie shoulder his
quirk is called double impact and that's
all we really know about his quirk his
last name refers to a palm strike and
his first name means two head combo he
also loves to watch boxing given this
information it's likely that meeting
Gehrke's quirk is related to physical
attack combination perhaps this quirk is
similar to derriere ease power from the
7w sims as long as his attacks aren't
interrupted each consecutive blow might
contain additional force compared to the
previous one you can only speculate for
now but that would certainly be a cool
quirk next up we have Pony suna Tori we
know that her quirk is called foreign
cannon we also saw her charging
headfirst during the cavalry battle
so her quirk must involve ramming things
or opponent's with the horns on her head
the cannon in the name of her quirks may
refer to the strong force with which she
Rams her opponent making it feel as if
they were being hit by cannon blasts or
perhaps she can extend or fire her horns
on her opponent as if they were cannon
balls her name includes the kanji for
horn and fetch
just like a real pony she loves apples
and she is the second confirmed
foreigner attending you a next we have
that a call Yanagi we know that her
quark is called poltergeist which is
defined as a ghost or other supernatural
being that is supposedly responsible for
physical disturbances such as loud
noises or objects being thrown around
the eCos name includes the kanji for
willow child and soul from the
information we have available along with
their overall goth like appearance we
can assume that her powers relate in
some way to ghost and the paranormal
perhaps she can see dead people and
control them to an extent or perhaps she
has a quirk similar to dark shadow
except instead of allowing her to host a
shadow like monster it allows her to
host a ghost-like monster and bonus fact
that a ghoul believe it or not is
actually a surfer chick she is really
into riding those waves next up we have
Judith Ishida we know that his work is
called beef just by looking at him you
can tell that Judith I was inspired by a
Henry Phillip McCoy aka beast from the
x-men this is not surprising you'll see
many references to both DC and marvel
comics in my hero academia since Kinoko
she loves western superheroes especially
spider-man as was the real McCoy do
turtles quirk likely gives him
superhuman strength speed and endurance
since he is part animal or beef he
probably has other animal related powers
such as an enhanced sense of smell his
name includes the country for beef and
she she is a homophone for lion and like
lions Dorota loves taking naps
next we have sin Chi but his work is
called swiveling but we don't know much
else about it sin is a plain looking
dude who likes cameras the name of his
quirk which means turning around on a
point or axis would suggest that he
utilizes turns or spins in combat next
up we have she haiku title his quirk is
called black he has one of the most
interesting designs his skin is
completely black and his cool white hair
hangs over his right eye his name
includes the country for black color and
domination my guess would be the like
Tetsuo tattoo in a steel form the black
skin is hardened and improves attack and
defense next up we asked
keno Keith Coleman
her quirk is called mushroom her name is
also a homophone for the Japanese word
for mushroom not to mention her
hairstyle which makes her look like a
human mushroom her quirk likely gives
chemical mushroom related powers
mushrooms can be toxic and medicinal so
it is possible that Kinoko can both
poison and cure people under the right
circumstances with her mushroom inspired
powers now I wonder how many times I
said the words mushroom and then we have
toe guru kamakiri his work is called
sharp blade and its type appears to be
mutant his design is super cool and he
totally reminds me of Scyther from
Pokemon it is interesting to note that
comic TV's name is a homophone for
praying mantis which definitely makes
sense so she kind of looks like one I
assumed that likes either kamakiri can
turn his arms into sharp blades which he
can use to attack his opponents perhaps
he can even turn other parts of his body
into sharp blades like mr. one from one
piece I will definitely look forward to
learning more about this epic looking
character next up we have setsuna talk
again her quirk is called autonomy in
English but the literal translation from
the Japanese is tail trip her last name
is a homophone for skink which is a type
of lizard known for its interesting
defense mechanism which involves the
dropping and regrowing of its tail she
also likes dinosaurs which makes sense
and setsuna's quirk seems to give her
reptile like powers she has very sharp
teeth and she can potentially shed and
regrow lost limbs her first name
includes the country for cut so it's
possible that she can use her sharp
teeth and nails to bite and cut
opponents like a lizard and last we have
manga Fuki dashi his quirk is called
comic and as we know his first name
manga is the name for Japanese comics
mangas head is a speech bubble it seems
that manga is more of a joke character
than anything else and surprise surprise
he even likes to draw since he is a joke
character I don't think he'll play a big
role in this series but it would be cool
if his power was to bring drawings to
life kind of like the first episode of
mushishi
where everything a boy draws with his
left hand comes to life I don't know
about you but I personally think that
that would be one of the coolest quirks
in the world of my hero academia but
anyways guys there it is everything we
know about class 1b and it works thanks
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this video especially those of you who
kept suggesting it obviously we don't
know as much about class 1b as we do
about class 1a but even if we don't know
exactly what each quirk does it's fun to
speculate let me know if you guys have
anything to add to the discussion or any
interesting theories about class 1b and
their quirks and if you did enjoy the
video make sure to Detroit smash that
like button and if you haven't already
subscribe for more my hero academia
videos and until next time see you space
Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]